the Joe Rogan experience how fortuitous
is it that you're writing about
infectious diseases and then this [ __ ]
goes down I mean if there's ever a
person who got a gift by a tragedy it's
crazy because I don't know that research
in the fall and into the early part of
the year did you go to Galveston the CDC
you know and I talked to doctors that
have been involved in infectious
diseases and with the weaponization of
infectious diseases and there's some
books out there I stuff online but the
online stuff you have to be able really
careful about and check with other
people that really know what they're
doing even though it's fiction so I done
all that part of it ahead of time so
what really changed for me as far as
what I'm doing now and what I'm
incorporating from this is what our
response has been took over 19 because
it's put obviously our economy into a
tailspin so what's the enemy doing the
enemy is looking at that and realizing
this this invisible virus has done to
the United States with the Soviet Union
couldn't do in 40 plus years of trying
so how do we incorporate that into
future battle plans can't we have a
strategy even though failure what if
there's just a threat of a bio attack
what if there is a failed bio attack
somewhere it's still gonna affect that
economy especially right now with us
being so gun-shy about all these sorts
of things so what are they taking from
that and what are they learning to apply
going forward so for my fourth novel I'm
taking those lessons of what the enemy
is learning from this and how they're
gonna how I think they're going to apply
it going forward and incorporating that
into a fictional narrative so in in that
sense I'm trying to yeah learn always
learning it's always important to learn
and apply it going forward and you
you're you're also you're in the middle
of writing this story but you're also
living a life of a person that actually
has to deal with this corona virus
pandemic where the whole world is kind
of shut down like as a just as a human
being when you're dealing with this
what's frustrating for you about how
everything is going down I you know I
think it's what we just talked about as
far as people not taking these lessons
seriously going forward and making this
a stronger country because of this so
you know you get knocked down you get
back up you're stronger for it you've
learned something like we talked about
in jiu-jitsu you know it's either you
learn
and so what are we gonna learn from that
we're gonna apply that going forward so
like the whole thing with the Iran
crisis we learn from that it applied
those lessons and we were more prepared
from 9/11 as a special operations force
because of it so for this I worry just
like you said our people are gonna go
back to their old ways after this they
can't wait to I can't wait to slide back
into their old ways yeah so how are we
gonna be a stronger citizenry maybe it
may be a certain percentage take these
lessons to heart
I don't know but so I think that's
probably the it's it's knowing that
people expect the government to take
care of them and that's the expectation
yeah not you it's not you don't have to
take care of yourself or your family the
government's gonna yeah how do I get
that what twelve hundred whatever that
whatever money they handed out oh great
well you know what's even better you
being strong self-reliant
self-sufficient and having your kids
look up and see how you're handling this
and say oh well the mom and dad are
either in the kitchen talking about how
much they're worried about paying that
ranch or that mortgage or they're in
that kitchen maybe talking about it even
if they are worried in a way like hey
how do we do this better
next time how do we prepare as on the
other side of this and one of the things
we can do now to get better prepared if
this happens two months from now a year
from now five years from now and the
kids can see that too or they see mom
and dad in the kitchen talking about hey
we are so lucky that we prepared for
this we were prepared financially we had
a little food here whatever it is and so
the kids will take those those lessons
on take those to heart because they're
very impressionable right now especially
at 14 12 and 9 and they're definitely
processing this and they're catching
things on the news and they're talking
to friends on their down social media
they're texting back and forth of all
that sort of things so this can either
make them stronger citizens going
forward or they can see mommy look mom
and dad relied on government we came out
the other side of this we got this check
and nothing really changed so Oh what
lesson are they gonna take going forward
right so it's a very important time not
just how you deal with this okay and how
you get through it now you move forward
better for it but because of the lessons
that we're teaching our kids whether we
mean to or not it doesn't have to be a
conscious thing like they're gonna take
lessons and as
it's up to us to figure out what those
lessons are gonna be and we can morph it
and make them stronger more self-reliant
going forward like our daughter sees our
freezers full of elk and moose and she
we pull that out which frost it and
she's she's a part of it because she
knows she got this elk in Colorado last
year now she's feeding our - how old is
your daughter she's 14
Wow she shot her first elk at 14 her
first elegant 10 go yeah no kidding
tagging New Mexico at 10 yeah so
somebody it was a retirement gift a
great guy and I said you know she gave
me two one for me and one for my wife or
moved me in with my daughter and I was
like you know what I got an elk last
year in New Mexico public land it was
crazy
crazy yeah but I was like you know can I
transfer that to to my wife my wife and
daughter go do this together and I'm
with them also an active family
experience and he was like yeah
absolutely that's let's do it and so she
was 10 yeah standing off sticks 310
yards one shot and the guide was he said
miss and she'd been hunting before she's
been hunting she was seven and she is
good and I was like oh you know I was a
tough shot hey it's okay how do you feel
about that shot she's like I feel good
I'm like oh it's just a ten-year old
saying that because they don't want to
kind of lose face in front of the guide
and mom's there and dad's there and I'm
like well it's okay you know it's okay
to miss everybody misses guess let's
learn from it move forward she's like I
didn't miss and say go up there there's
no blood there's no anything
we think we're tracking it we walk up
yeah yes you know she missed and we
walked back down and there's just little
tiny just ribbit in the ground if there
was 20 yards away Wow yeah amazing show
you picture after God feels stupid all
the way through he's on him back behind
you know but that's a problem right they
see the dust kick up behind the animal
and they think that it's a mess yeah so
yeah but you we have that meat from this
last year in Colorado oh that's amazing
about it with the family and she's like
she knows that she provided that for all
of us and was very exciting and
rewarding for her and their little guy
he's he got his first animal in Africa
this last year whoa yes I went back to
the crazy place to get your first day
yeah
so crazy so I've been over there doing
some more research I went to South
Africa to help
train up an anti-poaching unit because
they hadn't used Glocks hadn't used em
force a little bit of experience with
both those weapon systems and I want to
do some research in the art and science
of man tracking so I went to South
Africa helped train up this anti
poaching unit it was an amazing
experience and then they asked me to
come back as a thank-you to with my
family over the over the summer so I
came back with my with my family and our
little guy got his first animal there
they put the blood on his cheek except
this picture him in the back of the Land
Cruiser on the way back is he's never
had a haircut at age 9 so he's blond
hair blowing in the wind it's awesome
and then we use every piece of it that's
what's great about over there because
they see you use much more than we use
over here I mean stomach linings like
everything gets used in Africa which is
cool for them to see because they think
we're using it all here they see us
taking that rib meat and then neck meat
and all the rest of it
but over there they see everything get
used which is a pretty cool thing for
them to experience at that at that young
age so helps to be self-reliant - it's
and they see the people out there
working on the Land Cruisers they see
all everything you have to do in Africa
that you can just call someone to fix
the plumbing and call someone cuz the
electricity is out or whatever you fix
it yourself because you have to
[Applause]